welcome to the november 2021 meetup
it's good to have everyone here
still virtual obviously as we're always
tuning in from computers
one day we'll see each other in person
and we're actually starting to work on
that folks um i'll cover the meetups on
a little bit first we'll start with a
normal routine i'll talk about how we're
hopefully going to go back to in person
eventually
so first up jobs
i always like to start the meetup by
saying who's hiring
now we can't have everyone jump up and
say you're hiring because
actually none of you can actually get on
camera right now
so
if you go to the ny hacker slack which
is
nyhackar.slack.com if you want to join
there's a link at nyhackguard.org
slack.html we'll post it in the chat
you can go there there's a job postings
channel
in there post your job we have all sorts
of people who've gotten jobs from the
meetup both back in the before times and
now through that channel so please hop
in there and post a job and look for a
job
since
i am on screen i get to say my company
we are hiring both part-time and
full-time for
data scientists for shiny developers for
linux sysadmins for data scientists and
account account executives so we're
looking for all these roles in a
flexible arrangement remote in person
full-time part-time let me know and
that's one of the benefits of
being on camera i get to tell you all
that
so you want a job go to job postings
on our slack and nicole just posted them
in the chat so you can get to it
uh there might have been a problem
earlier with the if you're not already
member of the slack i know a lot of you
are but if you're not a member
there was a problem earlier but i think
we resolved it so that link should work
as there's tradition at the meetup going
strong for over a decade now i got pizza
so you do have the cheese lock test
holding them nicely the char tests you
sort of bubbling since it was cooked in
a pan see the little bubbling the
inverse bubbling
uh this is from village square pizza
they spent they have round slices too
but they specialize in a square slices
as the name implies village square pizza
i'm thoroughly enjoying this
uh i just had a vodka slice earlier it
was amazing so anyone let me know where
you got your pizza or other inferior
food product from let me know in the
chats and let's see what you're eating i
always enjoy either here in the chat or
in the slack chat let me know always
enjoy seeing where people are getting
their uh their food from in fact let me
open up i hear it's clicking a lot if i
could find it where did my slack go
oh david espanola was telling us that he
had dominoes
okay you know that happened that happens
oh brandon you made homemade pizza
that's really cool
and folks picks send pictures of your
pizza you also mind pizza let's see your
pizza send up pictures if you can i'd
love to see this
what else we got here
all right i see uh jd has something
coming let's see let's see what you're
saying
yes just recounting
doing what i can in suburbia here
i guess so i guess so all right fine
we'll let that pass you are speaking
tonight we'll survive
uh so while we wait to see everyone's
pizza photos if you have them we'll have
we want to thank ecohealth alliance for
providing the zoom link for us and i
believe noam from ecohealth alliance has
something like share of us
hey everyone uh good to see everyone
it's great to see uh jd haven't seen
since the long long ago many meet space
meetups um so uh normally i'm the silent
partner back here as eco health uh works
with uh new york r to sponsor the
virtual meetups as we have since last
april uh but
um i just wanted to jump in in my
capacity as uh lead for software review
for the our openside organization
because i we have a we have a meet up uh
in a few weeks that i thought this group
would be really interested in um
uh i karthik rahm male someone and arfan
smith who's product manager at github
for data and editor of the journal of
open source software uh are hosting a
community call we're going to talk about
our new infrastructure for
automated package checking uh editorial
peer review
and uh sort of chat based devops that
we've developed together working from uh
the
github sort of chat ops devops bot hubot
developing something for the journal of
open source software now our openside
which is our new sort of interactive
github package checking system and i
thought that would be something that uh
this group would be really interested in
so i'm gonna put a link for that
uh in the chat
right here as well as uh in the
um zoom chat for those who don't make it
over we think it'd be something that
this would be really interested in and
we're really proud of this because it's
something that we've built for our use
but is an open source tool that you'll
be able to start for your own
repositories our own internal
groups that might be interested in this
kind of peer-review system for quality
control which has been something we've
been pushing for a long time so uh
thanks for the chance to talk jared and
looking forward to your talk jd
great thank you gnome and i hope
everyone enjoys that uh the meetup if
you go to it um our open side is pretty
great i mean noam is awesome by himself
just alone that's great then our open
side is also really awesome to do lots
of great stuff for the community so i
hope everyone really enjoys going to
that it should be a good time
i do see john keane is making calzones
and i'm a big fan of the racket pizza
half pizza half calzone so thank you
john for uh for uh
including us in your journey tonight
next month
we have in addition to the monthly
meetup which i'll get to we have the
government and public sector art
conference this is now the fourth year
we've we've had the new york r
conference going for a while this is the
public sector conference where it's
about using r and friends there'll be r
python sql other tools or just general
statistics and data for either
government use or public sector
we have data journalists coming we have
people from
west point we have people from the air
force we have people from different
branches of government both federal and
local
it's really going to be a really great
time it's like a more focused version of
the r conference and we just added a few
new speakers in the past few days some
of them are cesary poe cool from
propublica
asamatumi from
pursue health but also the big data bowl
winner and david shore from
uh blue something consulting i forgot
the name of the company sorry david uh
but you know you david sure you may have
heard of him from a lot of his uh
political analysis so it's gonna be a
really great time that's just some of
our speakers we have a few more we're
going to be adding we have a few more
that have been there for a while on the
list um
come join if you want to join you know
these conferences we put on are supposed
to be essentially this meetup but
for two full days just full full days of
learning so since it's for members of
meetup you can use code ny hack r to get
20 off your tickets uh you go to
rstats.ai and in there you can find
information about the conference you
also find videos of all the past like
seven years up there and you can get
tickets and remember code ny hack r for
20 off
and our very own jd speaking tonight has
spoken at at least one of the
conferences and not more um so he's also
a repeat speaker here
in addition to the actual talks we have
workshops on so the conference oh by the
way the conference is december 9th and
10th
on december 8th we have two workshops
john hirsch is giving machine learning
for public policy and alex bogosian is
giving a talk about understanding
climate change data
so both of those should be really great
workshops you want to learn your skills
there are full day workshops the day
before the conference where you really
get to
get hands-on practical skills they're
going to be really cool workshops
um i'm always debating which one i
should go to but i've already taken
john's workshop so i'm going to go to
alex's because you know i haven't seen
that yet
john's is going to be awesome too if you
haven't taken it even if you have it'll
probably be good
so meetups we have coming up
next month before the conference either
the week before or like the day a few
days before we have to get the sac
schedule locked down we have the
intimidable max [ __ ] giving a talk
we are always yeah thank you
we are always excited
when max [ __ ] uh gives a talk either at
our conference or at the meetups he's
done both he's always awesome and a lot
of fun you're gonna learn a lot and
you're gonna have fun i can't see how
great that's gonna be so the december
meetup will be max [ __ ] the exact date
will be announced in the next few days
as soon as he texts me back because i
threatened him i was going to announce
the exact date today but i figured i'd
let him choose the date
then in january we have zj dai
talking about disc.frame
for those of you that don't know this is
a package that allows you to use dplyr
and data table operations
on a file on disk like a csv or a
collection of csvs it can be really
awesome
i've used disk frame a little bit in the
past i was really cool and i'm
interested in seeing so now arrow does
something very similar see john is here
tonight john keane i want to see how
they compare against each other we had a
we had wes mckinney and i think john or
neil or both spoke recently at the
conference about arrow now we have a
disc frame talk it's going to be cool to
see how these things are going i'm
really excited about this
then in february
we have hans mueller and hans if you're
here and i pronounce your name i
apologize we have hans muleson from
duckdb
going to be talking about using that in
general and i think with r maybe a
mantra is going to include r or not or
just be about duckdb those of you that
don't know duckdb is a very unpopular
popular in-memory database sort of like
sqlite but much more for analytics and
it uses arrow as a back end and they and
you can run deployer commands against
this database so this presentation i'm
giving today was just almost a duck db
because i've been i've been
experimenting with duckdb and arrow and
i just almost like threw all this away
and gave a presentation about that but i
didn't have time to actually go through
the r integration but it's such a neat
interesting package
it doesn't quite do what i think it's
supposed to on s3 but it's getting there
it's very early highly recommend it's
worth knowing about
nice perfect there you go so folks come
in february hans is one of the creators
of duckdb so come it all happened he
posted something on twitter he responded
to an r question so i messaged him hey
give a talk about it and he said yes
that's the way this works right post
something cool or just come ask me you
want to go talk be brave say hey i want
to give a talk right
so then
hopefully
in march
we're hoping to plan to make a return to
in person we have zero details now we're
just trying to figure out which venues
are comfortable hosting us so by the way
if you have a venue or an office that
can hold about 100 people or more
in new york city
let me know if you want to be a host
because we can't just rely on one venue
these things are a large thing to do so
we have multiple venues in the past
we've done ryze new york on 23rd street
we've done new york presbyterian we have
done
um i can't remember that incubator we
used to work out of that um on 19th
street and ebay used to host us aol
hosted us colombian nyu um two sigma i'm
sure there's a whole bunch of companies
i'm missing now so if you would like to
host us let me know
we are hoping again hoping to be back in
person in march we'll be coming with
this detail soon but we've got to
coordinate with a making sure it's safe
for everyone b make sure everyone's
comfortable and c finding a venue that's
willing to let a hundred people come
into their office for a meet up and
that's where things get tricky so we're
hoping if we can't do it in person it'll
be fully virtual if we are lucky enough
to do it in person it will be both in
person and on zoom um before the
pandemic we recorded and posted it to
youtube but now we're hopefully going to
have it live at the same time we will
hopefully get to that soon and fingers
crossed folks and march will be when we
get back to it and we can't do it before
then because two speakers are not from
new york so we can't do it until then jd
you're gonna say i was gonna say rajon
asking that in the chat about about the
continuing the virtual option and i
think it's fantastic he he's um he's
watching from chicago which is great i
had uh some of my colleagues in dublin
ireland were asking about wanting to
participate in this today it's getting
kind of late there i suspect they won't
be here there's someone from austria
saying they're here it's 1am right yeah
thank you for being here and we will
continue to do it virtually so rest
assured everybody there will still be
this virtual component live as it's
happening now that we have the
technology the technology didn't really
before the pandemic we had the
technology for the video but not the
audio the audio didn't work but now that
we have this oh we have someone from new
zealand wow you might win the record
well congratulations on uh on winning
that one and the home of r
so and i will fully say when i was at
the university of auckland they took me
to the room paul markup took me to the
room where i was invented and i took a
selfie of that room because i was so
excited to be in the room whenever i was
invented
so i'm very happy about this yes we will
continue the virtual component and we'll
try to make it as good and available for
everyone around the world to do because
i know we get people from all over
here's someone from florida yeah well
let me know where you're coming
oh yeah austria's home of crayons so
that's pretty cool yes the home of crane
coming
all right one last announcement we want
to get into our excellent talk australia
oh australia new zealand i think new
zealand wins for distance but i'll let
you two fight in the comments because
i'm not getting involved in that
historic battle
i hope everyone's excited for a good
time uh jd is someone who has long
before i even met him in person i knew
who he was
i remember when we back we had this at
aol
someone just mentioned his name in a
meetup and everyone wrapped it into
applause for the stuff he was doing this
is back then you think your aws package
or whatever was called original yes
segway segway yes it was segway yes yeah
he's
hi come on in we have a good visitor our
mascot yes hi do you want me to open
that for you did you get started yes
we're starting right now actually
so we have businesses
so everyone jd has been speaking at the
conferences at the meetups been active
on twitter
and he's just amazing so i will open up
here everyone please welcome jd call god
for him
thank you so much jared appreciate it
it's so fun to be here uh
good to talk to you guys from raleigh
north carolina uh which is where my
office is i live in richmond virginia um
let's see i guess i should share my
screen since i'm gonna present here let
me do that
all right we should have
screen action now
and this whole speaking into a void not
being able to at least see faces of
people when i talk like i really don't
like this because at least at work i got
faces that make me know i've been going
on too long but i don't have that here
so i'll just go on forever um
so this presentation was kind of spun
out of jared asked me hey you got
anything to share you've always up to
something interesting i've seen you [ __ ]
posting some stuff on twitter and i'm
like yeah i got some stuff but it's not
exactly like i'm gonna walk through a
package i don't really have a bunch of r
code i'm a live demo i've been thinking
about stuff and i've been working with a
team to test some things and he's like
can you make a presentation out of it
and i'm like yeah this is normally the
sort of stuff
we talk about at the bar but you know
hey we can't do that so this is sort of
the equivalent of that
now i know these slides are going to be
posted so i always include this slide
that said these don't stand alone go
watch the video
and we'll fill that in
uh later now
who am i
uh i'm co-author of the r cookbook
second edition with with paul teeter you
may know me for my prolific [ __ ] posting
on twitter about data analytics
parenting uh whatever um
and you may also if you signed up for
the uh for the slack room here you may
have seen me on um
this image
back from the new york r conference we
did things live and in person um
all right now i i i
i wish i could like poll easy so maybe
comment in the uh
in the in the slack uh
or let's see can i open the check okay i
can see chat now as well um has anybody
seen like this uh cat fight that's been
going on like in the the blogs back and
forth between snowflake and data bricks
is this a thing people have been exposed
to uh some of us that are close to the
data circles have seen this and it's
basically the the the gist of it and i i
do not use either product and i have no
connection to either teams like i don't
have a team here um
but the gist of it is is uh you know
snowflake responded to some post data
bricks and said they they weren't you
know doing their benchmarking right and
then then data breaks comes back and
says well snowflake did some
pre-processing of the data before they
ran the benchmarks and that's not cool
and so they're back and forth and i got
to tell you i 100 don't care at some
level like i just couldn't care any less
about two vendors pissing all over each
other's shoes what's interesting here
though is
that
they're obsessing over metrics and part
of the
of what i want to talk about is when it
comes to cloud sort of junk and
especially the the stuff that we do we
be in the people who come to like our
meetups
we are not typically
building uh data warehouses for the
entire organization right and this is
really what the whole snowflake data
bricks um gripe is about is is a data
warehouse benchmark we're usually trying
to do some workflow
that isn't a bog standard reporting data
warehouse and so what that means is
metrics which are often [ __ ] to
begin with are extra [ __ ] when it
comes to the things we care about
because it just doesn't capture what we
want and even when we sit down
being smart people who are used to
thinking analytically when it comes to
time for us to sit down with a tool
and evaluate them
we
often make this mistake that can be
called attribute substitution
surrogation or i love it because i'm an
economist street lamp analytics right
street lamp analytics is we search for
our keys not where we drop them but we
search them we're underneath the street
lamp because that's where the light is
um you know what we care about
and
we is one thing
but what we can easily measure
attracts us because we're analytical
people if we can make a metric and
especially we can carry that metric out
to four stupid meaningless decimal
points
we're gonna do that and then we're gonna
rank them right um and so we got to be
careful not to do that with with our
business metrics and also not do that
when we're picking uh tooling
uh for what we're doing so what i'm
going to tell some stories about looking
at tooling and thinking about like what
tools to use for certain type of
workflows um i i whoops i didn't mean to
advance
i need to real quick say a bunch of this
is done in the context of my employment
at renaissancery where i'm uh vp risk
management um
the stock trades down every time my name
is associated with the company so i just
want to acknowledge that i work there
i'm working with a bunch of smart people
who are smarter than me and they've
actually probably done all the work and
only thing that i contributed was
anything that's wrong in this
presentation and and the conclusions i'm
drawing here absolutely mine there if
you were to talk to people in it or
other parts of the organization who
worked with me they probably have very
different conclusions so it's my opinion
not the official opinion of where i work
and definitely not even the opinion of
my co-workers who i work closely with
um
so anyway with with that said
um
you know i i was chatting some of this
up in the in the process of prolific
[ __ ] posting and you know jackie and
brian fannin both both had this point of
view that really is going to be
foreshadowing for a little bit of what i
talk what i talk about you know they
both mentioned developer time developer
salaries you know the cost of developers
and often in our systems and what we do
those costs completely dwarf uh what
we're paying for computers hardware
compute time storage and s3
run time but
they end up in a different budget area
and so we don't
see that when we start measuring stuff
and so i feel like it's easy as we think
about these tooling to not appropriately
account for how long is it going to take
to get our workflow how many developers
and hours am i going to have to spend
either my time or a professional
developer who does it right
to how long is it going to take for them
to get something into production to to
do something that i'm trying to do now
if i'm trying to do a one-off it's
probably all my time if it's something
that's going to work regularly and my
work
probably going to need other people
involved right so we can't forget that
that's probably the most meaningful cost
so
this whole thing's gonna be in the
context of a story and and and i've
spoken out loud about this right i do a
lot of learning out loud both on twitter
and in person but uh in in twitter sort
of it gets captured for posterity so i
can go back and this is about six months
ago you know i raised this question of i
got five billion records
uh in a table
and and and then i got a hundred
thousand records in another table so
it's a mini to mini join i want to join
them together and get 25 billion records
um it's all in s3 parquet files and and
what should i what tools should i
consider
right and i mentioned spark desk and
drumeo because these are tools i'm
interested in um
got a bunch of great responses this is
all i don't delete my past tweets so you
can go find this and see what other
people uh responded
um
very thought provoking
um and i got a bunch of good ideas and
so like one
i'm gonna continue the story with you
know i i was like let let me go test
this and and multiple people that i
think highly basically said this is a
spark problem just use sparks don't
overthink this
um so i'm like okay so i went on amazon
stood up spark cluster in elastic
mapreduce um and
i made
um dummy data because that's what we do
right we start with some dummy data we
started i created dummy data that was
you know some data frames relatively the
size uh the right size
and uh i did a simplified version of the
logic that i thought contained like the
the meat of the logic but not everything
uh and i tried on spark and it ran in 45
seconds and i was like holy crap this is
so easy like that they're right just use
park and it's really trivial
and um
so i was like well i've had enough life
experience that i know i should
i know i should test with real data
because you know
there's probably some i know
it isn't shaped exactly like the real
data is so i went and got real data
data same number rows is the test data
same logic
and the actual run time was well over 30
minutes it was like 45 minutes
uh an hour depending on the cluster size
and so i immediately
was like what in the hell um but but i
understood my data so i sort of uh
quickly figured out what the problem is
and i was trying to figure out how to
communicate this to you all and here's
the best summary of why my real data was
not like my test data we had seven
thousand groups that i was you know
grouping by coming into this
and and five billion records our top 13
groups
so that's
0.2 percent were 40 of all the records
so they were 2 billion records just in
those 13
out of 7 000
groups
in the vernacular this would be high
class imbalance so if each of those were
classes
um
it's going to be highly imbalanced and
it's kind of when i learned the term
high class and balance that i realized
i had gone from i thought i was just
going to have an easy button two
all of a sudden i get a very rich
rich lexicon of crap that words that i
have never heard of just
a body of knowledge that i haven't been
exposed to in these large
data terms and as much as kind of like
all the vendor junk and people success
stories in their blogs or whatever kind
of make you think
all this stuff sorta just works
our observation was as our problem got
big and a little bit complex because of
these uneven groupings
the person who was using it
needs to rationalize about what's going
on underneath the abstraction
so we want it to not have to rationalize
about what's going on underneath the
abstraction i want these tooling to just
act like it's a data frame that has
you know 60 billion records and i can
just work on it like a data frame
the reality is at some point you can do
that for some size in some shape of
problems our problem kept hitting the
boundaries the only tool that that i
looked at in the process of trying to
figure this out where i didn't really
have to rationalize about what's going
on on the individual nodes was dremeo
and that's because dreamios really
designed to be an appliance uh way more
than than the other platforms i looked
at um so anyway but i'll talk more about
that i'm getting ahead of myself so
um
there's a few and i'm not going to spend
the whole presentation introducing you
to the language of stuff you should know
about with
these big distributed data
structures and systems but a few things
in this rich lexicon that you're gonna
have to need to know about pretty fast
in my opinion is classes that's the
thing i just talked about with the class
imbalance so like anything you you if
you think in sql terms it'd be anything
you group by or uh
anything you join by
uh those matter because uh some
operations will require or may work best
if an entire class is on one of your
worker notes so since you know i have 13
classes out of 7000 that are huge
if i have to put all of those on one
worker node that's a bunch of data
transfer and if two of those end up on
one worker node i'm probably overflowing
ram and i may be overflowing ram with
just one of those classes if it's the
one of the biggest ones so it starts i
have to start once again rationalizing
about what's going on underneath the
abstraction uh which is a lot more work
so
the other the other thing you have to
know about in addition to classes is
partitions and what's wonderful is
partitions has different meanings
that mean slightly different thing they
mean generally the same thing and that
is how the data is like chunked up
but if you write you can write a
partitioned parquet file out and arrow
has a way the arrow library has a way
for doing this and if you write it out
it will use and i just recently learned
this is called the hive key value naming
convention where it has a key and a
value and it needs a directory this way
and every one of those directories is a
partition
and those are great because it makes for
faster reads because if you just want to
read one partition it can go directly to
that uh folder with that partition on it
read only that and it doesn't even scan
the rest of the data okay those are kind
of kind of nifty that's a type of
partitioning there's also the type of
partitioning say with spark where you
when you read it into the system
how is it spreading those across all the
workers now in in that type partitioning
every partition
it does not break the data into every
partition it may be windows of
partitions across the nodes
uh so they don't always mean exactly the
same thing but they generally mean how
is it being chunked up
and then shuffle the term shuffle
meaning to transfer data between the
nodes in a distributed system and uh you
know shuffle is the costliest in terms
of runtime and io is the costliest thing
we do so you have to kind of understand
what causes shuffles and what uh how to
minimize shuffles and think about uh how
to organize your data in such a way to
make that less likely so
okay you can see pretty quickly we're
having to
think about this stuff and not just
hitting the easy button
um
another aspect of this
that
i quickly discovered is the the big five
the tension between the big file problem
and the small file problem
big and small are both problems so
there's this somewhere there's this
goldilocks size for your files that you
read in that's in the middle the big
file problem is
many of these systems have one reader
thread
per file per input file so that means if
you had six gigs in one file you get one
reader thread to read the whole thing
and that kind of sucks and
the flip side of that the opposite is
the small file problem so if you have uh
say 7000 groups like i do and you break
your data into
uh
7 000 individual files coming in
whatever system you're reading into pops
all of those open and reads the headers
and it parses the dirt carl's the
directory tree and all this garbage and
all that takes forever so you get a
bunch of like when it comes time to read
if you have 100 nodes you get 100 maybe
100 reader threads or more you may have
multiple threads per node which is great
you're doing a bunch of stuff in
parallel but it's got a it's got to
traverse all those files and directories
so when you have small files those
produce an inefficiency as well so you
got this tension between these these
optimal file size
problem all right so
here's my big data testing philosophy
that i have sort of uh begun to form as
i've been wrestling wrestling with this
problem wrestling sounds like i'm in
raleigh north carolina i'm gonna go
wrestling um when testing architecture
use data that's really the same size and
shape of your problem right and that was
my mistake beginning i must miss i
conflated row count with shape like row
count and columns that's not really the
shape right because the real shape would
include not just the row count and the
number of records but also the amount of
skew that's in those groups how a few of
the groups were really big
that's an example of like the real shape
of the data not just the dimensionality
of the tabular data that's going in i
didn't appreciate that a few months ago
until until i ran up against it um the
other thing that that we're trying to
always make sure that we do and this may
seem obvious to those who have done this
is
you you test an architecture with the
real shape data and then you test it
with multiple x
times that if you think the problem will
grow and like we think our problem will
grow so we looked at in which dimensions
uh and in which ways might this grow it
may grow that we need to do this process
i'm prototyping we may need to do it
multiple times a day
that's one type of growth we may get
more records in the data that's a
different kind of growth and so we need
to know can we do it with larger files
can we also do it multiple times at once
and some systems are better handling
that
than others
um
to answer
brandon hurst question because i caught
it on the corner of my eye i actually
really needed to
process all of the data i don't
necessarily need to load it all at once
so
raises a good question and i'll mention
some of this in some problems we had
with athena
when i get into this a little bit
farther
so one of the things a developer came to
me about a year ago and he said
you don't know which platform you want
to implement this workflow on right and
i'm like right and he's like
okay i think you should do it here and i
think that's what we should build i'm
like whoa you can't pick a platform
before you've even like prototyped and
he looked at me and he said i can't
build this
on all of them that's an awful lot of
time to build on all of them and i'm
like whoa this is a false deck out me
it's not pick one or build them all how
about we figure out which part of the
problem
is the hard part
and we try to implement just the hard
part on multiple different platforms to
understand how they behave with the hard
part of our problem
and that was a little bit of a of a new
way of thinking of it to him it seemed
really obvious to me and so i think it's
worth mentioning here that you know
you've got to have this i'm calling a
minimum viable data flow i mean it's
really minimal out product but i hate
thinking about this thing as a product
uh it's really what's the a data flow
that gives me a meaningful answer that
does the main steps i would want to do
and
we take that and we show just that
through multiple architectures even if
we have to do it kind of manually like
if i would not have my developer stand
up the infrastructure as code
bits to just test this
you know one workflow
that's way too big of a heavy lift like
do it more interactively or whatever the
easy on-ramp for that platform is and
test the flow and profile it a little
bit and understand the performance
bottlenecks so
i'll give an example in my problem i
said i had this was it like 5 billion
and i joined it to 100 000 and then i do
a bunch of aggregation after we do much
aggregation we do a bunch of sorting
i thought when i was going into this
problem that the sorting thing we did
towards the end
was gonna be slow and i was obsessed not
obsessed i was anchored a little bit to
that was going to be the problem and and
that's really where i was thinking about
all kinds of ways we could speed that up
as soon as i started profiling this
problem in spark i discovered that where
i do that first join
uh the 5 billion to 100 000 to end up
with 25 or 35 billion records
that join step
is the bottleneck it was more than half
of the run time uh meaningfully more
like two-thirds or three-quarters of the
run time of the whole process as i had
uh as i had spiked it out so i quickly
learned oh this is really all about how
do we make that very first step fast
and so then we could really focus on
that and so when we tested multiple
platforms we always tested that first
just to make sure we were doing that
reasonable
and then we could test other bits but we
wouldn't have figured that out if we
didn't do like a minimum viable data
flow first uh in one of the stories i
tell and i was on
dreamios subsurface podcast relatively
recently and got interviewed and i
talked a little bit about some of this
but one of the things i commented in
there and i will reiterate here is
when you go into
building a meaningfully large
complicated workflow what i discovered
is i learned two things i learned about
my pro things about my process that i
didn't understand and that's like me
understanding that that big join step is
the hard part and the other thing i
learned was i learned tons about the
tooling and what goes wrong and how it
falls over and all of that
i think that's normal because most of us
think we understand our problem and then
we don't understand how our problem
interacts with the systems we're trying
to use and so i think most of us
uh
learn a lot there so which platforms
should one think about right i'm telling
this all from my point of view but i
know folks are gonna listen to this
thing but what should i use you gotta
start with your organizational
constraints right if you're just analyst
all by yourself
uh you're freelancing or it's a side
project you can choose anything under
the sun so you've got a very wide set of
choices i was trying to solve problems
in the context of an organization so i
would be foolish if i didn't think about
this in the context of organizational
constraints so our organization tends to
have existing relationships with dremeo
with amazon aws
we also use use azure what we don't use
is much google compute we've
experimented a few things but we don't
have much going on over there
um
you know and i looked at it i think
google bigquery looks interesting i
would like to test our problem on google
bigquery but i know i'm going to need to
solve this problem
ultimately in a production environment
and when i say we i mean i mean i say me
i say i mean we as in the organization
so
i didn't even profile it in bigquery i
may consider that later as a novelty
but it doesn't fit in my organizational
constraints to do it there so the other
thing is
lots of folks and i think many of you
listening are already thinking he is
going to tell me at the end of this
what's the one ring to rule them all
this great thing that he discovered and
how it worked magically that is the
absolute wrong way to think about the
problem think about roadmap
thus my roadmap
uh not
what's the one
easy button or magic solution that's
gonna solve uh all of my problems
that mindset helps a lot the other thing
that's important and i talk about this i
use a lot of me
and i've caught myself a couple times
and said we um
you know
we joke a lot about teams and you know
together we can do the work one uh you
know and how much it slows us down to to
work in teams
this workflow i absolutely
no doubt in my mind
i understand the workflow better and we
got a better answer because we had
people from uh the business people were
consultants and specialists in
individual platforms and folks from my
it team
working together
to understand the problem and and
profile some tooling
i can't overstate how important that is
uh if i.t had run off without
involvement from the risk team we would
not have gotten his good answer if the
risk team had built this without input
from it and our consultants we would not
have gotten as good of an answer and
understood the systems as well it's just
really super useful to get multiple
perspectives
i call it the benevolent dictator
problem i love solutions that peel to
the exact way i understand the problem
right that that that's my narcissism and
this is classic overfitting i have a
model
this is how i see the world and when i
go out and pick solutions i pick them
according to that model which is ends up
with solutions that are over fit to my
myopia uh so it's it work on teams right
and get other people involved
some of the people in addition to my
fellow employees we've been working with
with four theorem uh out of dublin
ireland and and these guys are great
uh we had owen and um
mark hodnett now mark's got an r
connection he wrote the r deep learning
essentials uh book with pact so i got to
give him a holler out because we're in
our meetup and and owen despite his
profile picture on twitter is not a
leprechaun and i was really disappointed
to discover that
they have been great and tremendously
helpful uh in understanding systems and
how these uh web-based systems should
and could be plumbed together they've
taught me so much
now when i say a road map here's an
example this was absolutely put together
by me and i threw it out to the guys
other other ones on the team as a straw
man for them to uh to talk to me about
it this is an example of a road map of
how i think about
dremeo athena glue
amazon emr and desk
my sort of framework is you know is sql
enough to solve my problem because right
off the bat if sql is enough
um i'm going to probably want to use
dremeo or athena under certain
situations because both of these are sql
engines sitting on top of part k files
in s3 and nothing could be like more
straightforward
from an analyst point of view than
interacting with rk files using um
in s3 using sql it's just super
straightforward
you know but sometimes sql is not enough
and if sql is not enough you got to
actually do more code than that
well it pushes down and say well do i
care about cluster latency if i do
then i really should be looking at at
amazon glue now you see here that amazon
glue and emr are both spark what's the
difference
glue is a hot cluster so it's hot glue
um
by hot cluster i mean it's up and
running so if i ask for
50
nodes on glue i get them in eight
seconds or something like that under 10
seconds
um
but if i do that over on emr it's got to
stand the nodes up so that may take 5-10
minutes 15 minutes
and so if i'm just looking for things
fast it's hard to beat amazon glue now
the downside is amazon glue only get two
worker types uh because they have hot no
baby and amazon have
pools of these things up and running and
they don't want to have pools of every
possible permutation i said two worker
types i think there's actually three i
kind of ignored the smallest uh type
because it was a pain in my butt and i
just thought about the other two um so
anyway i think it's actually three but
anyway there's a very limited number of
worker types emr you can stand up on
absolutely any size that uh that that
ec2 machines that that they have
available um
but they take longer to stand up now you
know do you need tight python
integration uh for those of you who work
with python we work quite a bit with
python sometimes it would be very nice
to have uh
like
pandas data frame
sharded out across lots of workers
that's exactly one of the one of the
things the desk does
and we can stand up a dash cluster using
aws fargate or we can stand up a dash
cluster using services from tools like
sorry from vendors like coiled and we
contracted with coiled
to help us with this poc and had a great
experience uh working with them they
were super responsive helped us
understand how to stand up our cluster
on their hardware it was trivial well
their their system use it's amazon's uh
hardware uh we found for our workflow
it's not quite the right tool uh and
also the dash ecosystem is not as mature
as as the spark ecosystem
and i think that we definitely have desk
on our radar of technologies i want to
watch and i also want to test them
excuse me more than just the data frame
way of using das so das can be used as
data frame or as a handful of other ways
there's a lot of interesting things
going on in the dash ecosystem it wasn't
quite the right tool for our problem
for a number of reasons we've talked
those over with coiled they've been very
receptive and they have said yes okay
this is a problem and as a matter of
fact we got two open
um
uh feature well i don't know if sure
their future requests or um
issues
on
desk
because of this profiling work that we
did with them that's a great outcome
their products going to be better the
ass tools can be better than open source
version
and we're going to keep watching it and
may use it for other things in the
future uh you know other things we would
consider do you need spot instances how
frequency frequently are you going to
run and how much developer time uh
can you or should you throw at the
process uh because if you have a lot of
developer time or you're willing to
incur the fixed cost for a bunch of
developer time up front you may say okay
i can get lower run time lower
aws costs by spending more developer
time up front so you got to trade off
that fixed cost of developer time up
front with the marginal cost of
decreased run time
as you run these jobs and so that's
obviously obviously the wild calculus
there is
how many times you can run this a day
and over how many years in order to
recoup your your development cost so
these are the sort of things about how
we how we think about this
all right
so there's some unexpected constraints
that we saw as we started thinking about
these big data tooling things like how
easy or hard for business domain experts
to collaborate with the tooling so if
the
tooling is very difficult for those of
us say like myself who
have a deep domain experience in the uh
in the business
to collaborate and test logic with the
professional developers we're going to
move slow
um you know but if i can just write up
examples in sql and they can implement
those in sql
that makes a really fast feedback back
loop for how we get things done so
that's kind of not something i hear a
lot of folks talking about is well how
easy is it the tool for your developers
to work closely with business experts
right now part of it is we have really
incredibly technical business
uh users i'm a business user and i wrote
on our book um so clearly maybe more
technical than you might find in
accounting so we want to be in the guts
of whatever it is we're in because the
nature of what we're doing we need to be
in there with our professional
developers and so how easy or how hard
is that
um deployment and maintenance
so how hard is it to do changes in logic
how hard is it to deploy the solution if
you're going to use it say
productionless where you're running it
lots and lots
you know maybe daily or multiple times a
day and like one of the wild cards in
all systems is complexity right
complexity has a cost and
um
it's really hard to value that
appropriately
but the older i get the more i value
simple solutions because i've just paid
the hidden penalty cost for complexity
too much over my life
all right
since i know y'all ask and i don't think
i can give a presentation like this
without some sort of indicative
benchmarking
let me tell you this all right so what
was our least expensive run when we
profiled this job on everything the
least expensive run we did was on amazon
athena
and the reason is is athena pays only
for for the data you scan so you can get
an awful lot of compute
pretty cheap and i mean i think it was
like under a buck when some of the
solutions we were throwing 30 or 40
bucks a run at
to give you a relative ballpark i'm not
don't quote me on exactly those numbers
but you know orders of magnitude
more
um
on some platforms than on amazon athena
the downside of athena is we had
initially ruled out amazon athena
because first time we tried to run our
job on it it literally just ran for an
hour and then failed and we're like well
that doesn't work and kind of gave up on
it
and mark who i mentioned earlier before
theorem who i should know is the smart
guy right because he wrote a deep
learning in our book uh he was like let
me play a little bit with this athena i
think we can make this work and i'm like
whatever knock yourself out dude and he
went in there and he chunk he ran it in
chunks and he also
uh
knew you can run up to 20 queries in
parallel
and so we ran 20 queries in parallel on
chunks of data and was able to make our
workflow work and it was not the fastest
runtime
but it was
absolutely the cheapest but it required
more development time right because he
had to chunk it on the beginning so
trade-offs
um the dev favorite
excuse me just one second i need to
clear my throat
the dev favorite
was amazon glue
and by dev favorite i mean one of the
devs on the team was his favorite um
and it was a it was a commonly positive
thought of tool uh because that with
amazon go you get a hot spark cluster
that's very easy to interact with
not without nuance or quirks though
we found there's multiple ways of
relating to it and they had kind of
different performance and we're not
sure we understand that there's some
abstractions that they they being amazon
have built on top of
um spark that we're suspicious we're
slowing us down but we're not 100 sure
uh so some questions there we'd like to
understand better what will we probably
build our first gen of this workflow in
trimia
why will we do it because it's drop dead
simple to implement with
um
we probably won't well we may or may not
i can't say we probably want we may or
may not stay there long we may change
the workflow somewhere else but
we can take our quants and our
developers and we can implement a
solution right there and have an up and
running uh really fast and
as we grow we likely will want it out
and onto a different platform uh we may
not be able to get the licensing terms
we want with dremeo but because we're
just with dremeo doing
sql
on top of s3 it's super easy
to migrate it out of that environment
if we think we need to later so once
again it's a very reversible solution
and it kind of fits right into our
ecosystem if you didn't have a dreamio
um you know dreamio is our uh
tooling we're using for um
um
data lake uh solutions already so we had
drumeo on-prem right and it's like well
let's see if we can just use it for this
other workflow
uh and we and we did and so we will be
profiling that but you know this is kind
of an r meetup open data r but but but
what about r and python what does you
know especially r um
think about these workflows as
you know how in in unix or linux we
would like
pipe csvs between things and csv was the
common language and all of our uh
tooling could be loosely coupled you
know if we use csvs in between them the
new csv is part k files and
the place to put them is s3 if you're in
amazon right so we can think about
all of our workflows are these loosely
coupled pieces
with parquet and s3 in between the
chunks so we may use amazon glue and
then put the results there and then put
dremeo on top of those results and with
python and r
we can look at the s3 and interact with
the resulting uh look at the sorry
parquet files in s3 at any point along
the way we can also connect them to
tools like dremeo using
you know jdbc or other database connect
connection methods to
connect with them as if they are a data
source and then do
all of the normal stuff that we do with
data sources and we can even you know
write sql that creates new tables and
those new tables are just more
uh parquet files in s3 so
we begin back if we think about what are
the roots of
r
right the roots of it is this easier to
use interface around fortran programs
and have graphing right and be able to
graph the output of these you know
fortran uh
science libraries well we're still kind
of there in that we're using r or python
as
a little bit of orchestration and a
little bit of like doing some reporting
grabbing a piece of data and we're using
instead of you know fortran libraries
behind it it's maybe our cloud libraries
behind it and our data is remote instead
of being on our local machine but we're
still leaning on what is useful in these
tools are in python
easy to write
the code is it's easy to read
uh it's
pretty output in terms of graphics and
we can do a bunch of quick analysis on
it all that's still in play we just got
it laying on top of different stuff in
the background
um so ecosystems it's all about
ecosystems and and this is i'm just
about wrapping up i got two more slides
so jared should be getting ready with
questions um
and
there's two ways to think about the
ecosystem we look at the apache arrow
project they have one approach right
there are python libraries for arrow and
there's our live python library for
arrow and there's our library for arrow
and they both sort of interact with the
low level c plus api and give you access
to it in your high-level language but
you have your own you know
library or your own library in your
language that you interact with those
and they have slightly different uh
things implemented different times so
parts of the r library has stuff that
python doesn't yet have right now
interestingly enough and i'm sure it'll
be added to the python library later
an alternative is
if we look at the r athena
library that's in cran
the way it works
is it uses boto3 which is an interface
into
the aws ecosystem for python
and then it lays a reticulate on top of
that
and then you use r on top of all that to
basically get to
the aws tooling
through
uh reticulate python boto
aws and you can interact with
some of the the are the athena uh tables
and mount them as if they're a database
connection
that's kind of an interesting model as
well so you'd end up not having a
separate
library for each you use reticulate to
give you like the boto library which is
is is the python way of talking to uh
amazon web services it just lets r have
access through python that's a different
model also quite interesting so we'll
see these ecosystems uh develop both
ways i am sure
um one thing you should know about if
you're playing around in any of this
world
of stuff with aws is you should know
about the aws data wrangler library this
python library
it's data frame citrix so pandas for
moving things around in in the aws
ecosystem uh easy integration i listed
here athena glue red shift s3 a whole
bunch of other junk in aws those are
kind of ones that i use a lot um you
know if you've ever used um
any of this stuff and you thought why
can't i just read you know
some of this from s3 into a pandas data
frame well that's the kind of stuff the
datawrangler does or if you say oh i
wish i could just easily from python
copy this file to that bucket
uh boto3 lets you do that but it takes a
few steps
aws
datawrangler lets you do that kind of
with one assertive command so you can
say boto 3 is like a lower level api
while aws data ring there's a higher
level
api with more emphasis on etl kind of
work so
i recommend going checking that out if
you're mucking around this in this
ecosystem python at all
so
i haven't shown you any any r code and
i'm not gonna uh but we are going to
open this up for questions so i'm gonna
stop sharing my screen
and jared you to come on and uh and do q
a with me
yes
uh so the first question was what brand
beer shampoo do you use
a beer champa so let's see i uh i have
my gym kit right over here now i just
use whatever shampoo i'm using thank you
for asking but i do use a beard oil or
you get dry skin and nobody wants to
show up with beard dandruff that's not a
good look doesn't look classy
i agree good good to know it's good to
have these uh these these tips
um in terms of your presentation um i'm
not sure you actually said this or not
you said which method was the cheapest
which was the fastest overall to make
our whole run
that's a good question i don't have the
answer right off the top of my head but
i believe that it was uh
probably it was one of the spark methods
where we could effectively put it on
great big
servers
so i think it was it probably was it was
an emr
uh or it may have been
it may have been sparked on directly on
ec2
um
one of those two but it was basically we
could stand up a whole bunch of big
machines it was incredibly expensive
you know as opposed to like athena was a
buck this was something that was more
like you know
100 bucks an hour now our job didn't
take an hour so we would pay fractional
of that but it was it was orders of
magnitude more expensive
so along those lines you mentioned a big
machine is
three big machines better than 50
smaller machines
totally defend depends on your problem
this is where that uneven grouping thing
i didn't understand this when i started
all this but that
where we have this problem where a few
of our classes i call them groups but
our classes are really big
our problem works best and it works
easiest if during one of the steps you
get everything from a class on
one node so if that node is not very big
i start spilling the disk or it just
blows up so this is one of the things we
ran into in das
is
if the machine size was under under
provision
das blows up
if on spark if the machine size is under
provisioned it just thrashes to disk so
it slows down but it doesn't just blow
up and it'll ultimately finish just kind
of slow uh so like they have very
different failure modes if your node
size is picked wrong which is kind of
like something you need to understand
when you go through and do this um
and
so what we learned is at some point as
soon as we had a node size that was big
enough
that our
least balanced group would fit
completely on it
we were in pretty good shape
but if our nodes are too small like our
job just wouldn't run at all or it would
take just forever because of the
thrashing the disk um
along with that is any of these if
you're if you're doing like if you're
just doing a one-off job a bunch of this
optimization doesn't matter you're just
trying to get something that runs right
and that's fine but if you start if
you're like gonna have something you're
gonna run this thing multiple times a
day for years
pay somebody who's an expert on one of
these platforms to help you read the
execution plan
and look at your performance metrics and
understand what it does because none of
us can be experts in all this stuff
that's exactly what you should be
throwing consulting dollars at you know
we were using consultants from four
theorem and in addition got consultants
from the individual platforms who had
deep platforms uh specialists you know
with with dremeo with coiled or spark to
come in and
like help us read our execution plans
and make sure we ended like there wasn't
some stupid mistake we were making that
would make it a much like picking the
wrong node size made sure that like they
because it's not going to scream at you
to do that you got to look and read in
the logs and realize oh we're thrashing
the disc or oh or you know where we're
spilling over out of our ram and that's
a sign that we need to do this that
stuff
not there's no easy button for that in
my opinion
and
is it possible to
have
different note sizes because why have
just a bunch of giant ones like giant
let's mix the medium and small ones and
different tasks intelligently go to the
different parts
there is nothing that manages that
dynamically in my opinion now the way
that gets implemented in practice is
tools what tools like dremeo do
is we have different size clusters that
are based on different size machines and
it will create a query plan and based on
its anticipated size of the query plan
it'll route the job to a different queue
which runs on different node sizes
so in that regard you're sort of doing
what you say but it's a fairly naive
cut right it's just saying oh this is a
long running query we'll put it in the
long running queue that has bigger nodes
this is a fast one we'll put it you know
over here and some of what that is is
like our our queue for really long
running stuff we don't keep it standing
up because it's expensive so it times
out after 30 minutes and shuts the notes
down and so if i want to run a really
big query it's got to wait
five or ten minutes for that cluster to
stand up
and then it runs and does its thing and
we're fine with that uh but you just we
just got to know that it's going to do
that as opposed to if we run a small
query we keep the small engine runs you
know during uh like business hours it's
always running and so there's no lag
there
but none of the other systems that i
interacted with do anything like that
and as a matter of fact you have very
you know i pointed out that glue you
have two or three
uh node sizes
uh similar on athena it's completely
serverless you have no choice of node
size at all it just is sort of you get a
you get executors um and you know but
you go over to ec2
you can choose your node size but it's
kind of up to you to figure it out for
every every time you stand up a cluster
you got to make that choice you can
stand it up on different sizes but it's
up to the user to pick that right
okay
um
continue along that round by the way
folks i have a bunch of questions here
if you have more
put them in we'll see which ones we get
to
in fact there is this one didn't copy it
did okay quick okay
um
let's see
well you made it you talked about is
this is just gonna be a joke that i had
you talk about jeremy on their data lake
how about their data lake house do they
offer you that oh i know seriously i i
i have so much problem with these
vendors because i just want to mock them
for the naming right and if that's not a
healthy relationship with people that
you're trying to have a professional
ongoing relationship with
uh but i've just about but between it's
like just when i thought that was all
ridiculous and i was
kind of beginning to understand what
they meant people started introducing
data fabric versus data mesh versus data
velcro
and then they started saying it's not
etls it's reverse etl and i'm like i'm
getting too old for this [ __ ] y'all just
need to shut up
remember murdoch i know he's always too
old he always went for it
that's true that's true and it's like i
i have lots of patience for the actual
workflows but the names that i think are
nothing but marketing gimmicks are what
i have no patience for i'm like tell me
what problem you're solving and stop
trying to come up with a qts name
um
let's see i had a couple of questions
here that let me let me respond to one
was about getting
data into s3 um
a bunch of what we were doing
takes place in s3
so the the upstream process that
generates it is already there
so uh when i do testing
i shove stuff in s3 using uh the aws
command line tools
uh from
[Music]
excuse me from linux command prompt or
if i'm in in python i use uh i use the
aws data wrangler tooling to
copy stuff over to s3 buckets um
one thing
i don't know that's worth kind of
commenting here i'm not sure really
where this fits in
but when it comes time to slurp data out
of the cloud
and and maybe back to on-prem
some tooling will allow you to to read
and parallel
through multiple
nodes uh and other tooling shoves it
through one connection like anything
that's got uh
dbc on the end of it for the most part
you know jdbc or odbc is going to shove
through a single node
back to your database connection i mean
that is what the standard the the the
dbc
standards my understanding is they don't
have any any concept of parallelization
built into them so they got to come to a
single stream uh but if you're using
other tooling it may read and write to
and from s3 in parallel which can be
kind of nice right so you can fully
saturate your uh your home internet
while your wife is watching tv that's
groovy
just just don't take it down completely
um so but you have more questions but
there's one that seems sort of related
to that just
someone asked about bypassing corrupt
parquet files how do you handle that
oh that was the one about the the
corruption oh yeah how do you bypass a
corrupt parque file in athena yeah i've
literally never had this problem and
that's not to say i want i just hadn't
thought about it because i've just never
run into it so i guess as soon as i have
this problem
what i will do is i will go to my uh
consultants who do a lot more cloud
stuff at scale
and ask them
uh and i am suspicious
they will say to me something like oh
then we switch to serial mode where we
re read the files one by one and figure
out which one has a problem and skip it
and then read all the others right i'm
suspicious they have some fallback plan
like that i just have i just haven't met
fight with yet well
john keen and neil richardson are here
so just feel free to contact them
directly oh fantastic
yeah that's what i like to do so neil
john you're under the bus now
i'll call them as soon as i have that
problem exactly
as much as you
um
walter asked about i'm kind of avoiding
this one about the the server and
cluster approach
for example tile db everything is an
array
i i haven't dealt with tile db as a
matter of fact i didn't even know that
was a thing i don't even recognize the
name so i'm a little clueless there um
one sort of
um i should point out that the
the dasc library for python it has
multiple um
i'm not sure if api's or ways of using
it is the right thing it has one at
different abstractions one abstraction
is a data frame abstraction and you
relate to this distributed data frame as
if it is one data frame but in reality
different row chunks are on different
machines but you
relate to it as if it's all one big
thing
it also has a state for uh for numpy
arrays so you could do the same thing
with an omp array you don't have to
think when you're coding it you know
which shard is on which worker anything
you're just relating to this one really
big numpy array um
and then it also has effectively a
parallel apply so you can do an iterator
and it spreads those jobs of of like
doing doing the work of that across all
the worker nodes
these are all python abstractions and
that's three of the
interfaces and it's got at least five so
i can't i can't remember oh there's one
that's that's dag that's a dag related
uh construct so it's got a number of
different ways you relate to
it uh we found in the
um
in the data frame abstraction
their shuffle algorithm
is not as efficient as some shuffle
algorithms it's not awful it's not bad
it's just our problem is really big and
we have two steps that basically demand
a shuffle
and so we struggled a little bit with
making desk uh
do well with our problem because of the
needing to shuffle and there's not
shuffling so so well at this scale now a
lot of folks can do a lot of stuff with
desk and never see the problem we have
so once again this my experience does
not um does not transfer to everyone's
problem right we looked at this and
we're looking all these toolings in the
context of the specific problem we were
trying to solve
and then uh brian pointed out in the
chat that dark annabelle was working on
tile db
oh okay well it's probably awesome
yeah well my first thought when i saw
tile to be it sounds a lot like side db
which brian worked on
so yeah
i don't know how close it is but that's
my first thought oh this sounds like a
side db but yeah so todd to be on and
dirk actually gave i think might have
been a virtual user might have been
something else give a whole tutorial
about using r with tile db
okay actually i just opened up the
website and i'm sorry i have seen this i
just didn't recognize the name for some
reason written down i don't know if it's
because it didn't have the little square
brackets around tile
uh the way that they do it but i i have
seen that and if if dirk's working on it
it
probably is uh fantastically performant
right i mean his whole background is
with very you know uh folks that don't
know he does the the c plus uh
libraries
in uh in our and has a very high
performance background the stuff he
makes tends to be like very fast uh so
it's probably done right done fast and
something i need to learn more about
and since brian is in the chat brian how
similar is this to scidb another thing
that um i think stone breaker you worked
on a stone breaker a while ago because
to me then i hear arrayback databases of
an r interface to me they sound similar
so brian let us know in the chat and at
least for my notification oh similar
great perfect thanks
cool
uh ryan asked about if athena could be
set up for dealing with streaming data
i struggle a little bit streaming data
because everybody's definition of
streaming data is kind of different
usually what streaming data is just
means rapidly updating small chunks of
data
the the whole athena as far as i
understand it
uh when you run your query it looks at
park pay files and s3 buckets so if
those are coming in
uh some every second it will deal with
what's there
so
if you are comfortable doing batches as
your stream which has to be rk files
dropping off there accumulate that could
be possible
but streaming in that context is not
something i do uh so it's not something
i i know very much about
streaming is netflix for you
yeah exactly streaming is
what my parallel downloads from uh
from s3 break that my wife is doing
um
there's
a few questions and this is one that um
there's some talk about price but
you mentioned how debt time is more
expensive than the tooling time right
but cloud time
cost can really accelerate and you
mentioned before you're doing this once
you're doing this 10 times a day where
do you find that balance between
developer and then also this thing's
going to be running thousands of times a
year how much that's going to cost you
where do you balance yeah i mean
what we do is is this is classic
operations right so i would just do
do the math right do the napkin um
how much dev time do we think we're
gonna spend multiply that by 10 to get a
correct number and then you
that was a development time creep joke
um and then
you also just look at how many times you
use it and over what lifetime right so
what do you think the lifetime of it how
many times a day over how many years
uh how does that add up and yeah
absolutely you can easily run into
situations where the run time
you know if you're running it 10 times a
day you got 250 work days in the year um
that's
uh 10 sorry 10 times a day that's 2500
times
a year
um you know if you can
do it for
uh
you know one dollar versus ten dollars
you start to say okay i can pay a lot of
developers on that kind of delta
uh but if you triangulate it and you're
like
the expensive method
costs 2500 bucks a year and the cheap
method costs 1200 a year
like i i can't get a developer
to get his head around my problem for
1200 worth of development time right he
doesn't understand my problem after he
spent
twenty five hundred dollars worth of
time right he's still he's still trying
to figure out what where the bottleneck
is and so there's got to be a meaningful
uh you know tens of thousands of dollars
of of of savings before you should
really start
for example
building a whole internal architecture
to make the problem faster now i'm not
talking about developer just to you know
build a little bit of something i'm
talking like you got to build a whole
bunch of plumbing to to do a job
something that might take two weeks of
developer time
be sure you need it
um there's a question
i think paul asked this question two
places so i think he really wants it
asked okay
is there a way to calculate the price
performance of your alternatives you
could have used to compare them
yeah so the price the price for one
basically um
how am i comparing the price of them
is that what we're asking yeah i guess
so like without running it and building
it could you like speculate how much it
would have caused
well i guess that's what you're asking
like speculating how much it would have
cost you without actually running
through it okay so so this is called
bench racing right this this is what
mechanics do all the time and
i am of the opinion that when it comes
to guys sitting around with highly
linear systems without a bunch of
feedback loops you can do this pretty
well so my guys down at my local speed
shop can compare a board out 350
to a bog standard 454 and talk about the
systems that are around them and tell
you how those would perform in a drag
race or something right they can do that
because those are well tested systems
they understand
and so if you are doing
a process that is well understood the
way that a small block chevy is well
understood in that community
you can do bench racing with your
performance my life experience says all
of my problems do not fit that profile
and i gotta actually run code
and the reason is is there's
too many surprises
there's too many like
situations where
like we ran into with uh desk an example
of we have two shuffles that we have to
do
um and
they have like an alternative shuffling
method
but it like and i can't remember the
exact deal but like it only worked well
if you only do one shuffle but as soon
as you have to do a second shuffle it
actually makes your second one slower
how in the hell when you're bench racing
this do you ever understand and
anticipate that
you can't i'm convinced so if you're
really doing simple jobs and they match
benchmarks and they're well understood i
think you can i think otherwise this is
the importance of doing what what i
would call this minimum viable workflow
or minimum viable data flow you really
gotta test the bottlenecks in multiple
systems because they're not super well
understood
and your problem probably if it's super
simple and very symmetrical well shaped
and well behaved you might be able to
get away with that
but but i highly recommend folks do
uh
testing stuff out now
this is uh it's rampant empiricism right
and he's basically saying can we do this
with a model
instead of empirically testing and i am
a rampant empiricist i think that that
we need to
really
do the the testing
okay i'm and i saw paul say no so he may
have missed under oh all right
uh
i'm still i wish i wish i could just
like phone paul in here
[Laughter]
alternatives that you see some of the
internals you could have used to compare
them so i'm not sure
yeah i i'm not sure i understand the
question i could keep guessing i mean
after i built them yes i just run them
and i look at the aws cost and the rent
time so i'm missing something
it's not the cause of what you could
have built though yeah that's true
that's true
well paul i'm doing this pop polio yeah
more information let us know
or call me i'll hold up the phone too
i wish we could just all go out and
drink bourbon and actually fall and talk
about that that's what i missed so we
will do that next time i'm in new york
for those of you that are you're a
regular person right house closed
yes
yes that was very hard on me
um luckily lily's down the street is
still open but it you know
lily's you know i like i love the lilies
but right house you see john just
trapped and that was a mainstay well i
think one but we were all a little too
old for lilly's we're all going to write
a house and it was great
and um it's very sad and everything all
these stools i walk past it all the time
the stools are still there on top of the
bars if like they just closed up and
left and never came back it's um oh man
it's been really sad
yeah
yeah that was that was a homey place and
even like um the manager um
uh tron i was texting him like hey what
happened it's just yeah it's been bad
yeah dusty just rolling it it's bad
about right house it's really sad so
next time we're just all coming over to
jared's house
come on over
we got it
yeah absolutely
and i have enough i do have enough
burping around to make even jd happy
um we'll get back to your questions in a
second walter's asking what part of new
york that was union square it's like
17th a block away from union square
that's where we held a lot of the
meetups um but a whole bunch of the
meetups at different offices right
around that area we kept getting off
space in this area um between twitter
ebay pivotal some other ones um
also right house is our home base for
years
it was so good like they know we were
coming and telling them they're coming
on thursday night they cleared a whole
back room for all the nurses to hang out
in
it's pretty good after one of the
conferences i brought my camera and got
some really dope pictures in the back
with no i was using no flash and now
with my dslr
and got some really cool pictures one of
my favorite pictures you took in the gun
i think a lot of people appreciate this
was of david robinson a starched tie
diverse person
with jeff ryan
exactly right first person the two of
them
debating like you know it's like this
medieval drama the renaissance drama in
this photo that jd took it was amazing
it was it was i saw that conversation
going on i just started snapping
pictures i'm like this is bound to look
interesting especially if you know the
people involved
and i purposely scheduled their talks
back to back because they wanted to
go against each other
so back to questions about this
um
is there do you have any recommendations
for intro reading on athena and s3 for
our users
oh okay so
uh for for athena uh
it's much more straightforward there's
at least three packages well there's
three ways of connecting to uh athena
from r so it's either use jdbc use odbc
or use the r athena package that uses
reticulate and goes in through the bodo
three door
good place to start is the our athena
package they have at least a user game
manual and possibly a vignette i'm not
completely sure on that
um
that would be a good exam a good a good
place to go to go peeking into it with a
lot of these tools
you kind of got to learn something about
the tool
and then you learn how to connect r to
it to use it right so it's not really
like they're an immediate extension of r
it's more like
it's a database
and you're connecting r to it now the
neat thing i have not used the r athena
library so i'm not
uh swearing by it or or recommending it
but like even it's kind of neat because
the the one built on top of articulate
still allows you to use your connection
to athena
in a db plier workflow so you can
connect to it and pipe it through dplyr
functions and it does the right thing
right because it's a database it acts
like a database underneath it and then
you can have athena just sitting on top
of s3 files so you're effectively
querying
parquet files on s3 using dplyr
is effectively what the experience
should be if it all works i have not
tested it all out to make sure it all
works i've been trying to get other
stuff going but you got to get some
point like if you're going to use athena
you got to go read an athena doc
uh and the amazon help files are pretty
good uh their their introduction to the
tools you've got to read something there
just to figure out what you're what
you're doing and figure out like how do
i've got these s3 files how do i make
them show up as a table it's not hard
but at some point you got to read the
docs to figure that out
um then
why was you might have said but why was
glue the favorite for the devs what made
it so okay
so what it was likable to them is uh it
had a shorter learning curve than um
than desk did
uh desk had kept we had a lot of gotchas
with desk where we ultimately figured
out how to do it but there was real uh
surprises along the way uh uh and one of
the one of the surprises and i was given
one of the best founders endless [ __ ]
about this on on twitter is if you have
a great big desk data frame spread
across multiple machines
if you do a group buy its default
behavior is to return the results well
you do a group buying an aggregate if
you do when you do that aggregate
after a group by it will try to return
whatever resulting records you have back
to one node of the cluster by default
the hell i got 7 000 groups and they're
huge
that's terrible default behavior from my
point of view
and because we would just like the very
first thing we did was group by and our
cluster would fall over and it's like
what
um and it turns out like when we rtfm
there's a way to tell it how to spread
that out across the cluster but that's
an example of we just kept stepping on
our own cuff
uh because of combination of immature
technology and
i would consider not real good defaults
in a few places
and so we liked a bunch of stuff about
about das
but we found the the getting somebody up
to speed where they could actually be
effective with it
took like
a developer focusing fully on that for a
couple of weeks to work through all
these hiccups that's a long time
just to get your head around like try to
make it work
the developers liked
liked glue because it was
um
easy to get up and running
uh they felt like spark was a little
more robust for the type of workflows
they were we were doing now the thing we
like about uh
desk is
if you're in if you're in python you
feel like you're using python when
you're using spark and you're in python
you feel like you're remote controlling
the jvm because you are
um you know and so you get
java heap error messages back and stuff
that are just like what the hell
um so that's a downside but the
combination of it was fast to get a good
enough answer
now we spent some more time and got them
faster as we figured out more things
about partitioning and chunking the data
even in glue we could make it faster but
it ran
and didn't fall over before we got it
fast so they like that and the whole hot
cluster thing the thing that you could
ask for nodes and in seven seconds you
could have 50 nodes
uh that's really neat
um you know and you're you're billed by
the second so you can stand up 50 nodes
uh have them in seven seconds execute a
job that takes two minutes
and tear that down and you only pay for
you know
ev literally every how many minutes it
was stood up
um and
that's kind of nice
and it took less um
it wasn't as fiddly as some of the some
of the solutions from the developer
point of view
now is glue a lot more expensive to run
than the alternatives because it comes
up so fast and down uh
more than the other spark methodologies
i don't think that it is but that you
raise an interesting question why would
you just always use glue instead of the
other ones
uh
limited choice in node size right you
got that three three node sizes that i
call too because the smallest ones are i
thought were useless so uh you only have
three node sizes um
and with the others you can have like
and you can choose any kind of node size
you want like with one of the ones based
on ec2 so if you use elastic mapreduce
for example you can choose any ec2 node
size
uh
and and use those but you also then have
to set all the switches
to make it work the way you want it to
do and we are not
you know me nor my team our spark
specialist so we liked in glue that all
the switches
were a good set of defaults because
amazon's picked stuff that works pretty
well right and there's something to be
said for letting someone with lots of
experience pick your defaults for you
and they set those defaults to match the
node size right so they're controlling
the node size and they're controlling so
things just kind of worked pretty fast
uh
that made the glue pretty useful
so we're gonna do like two more i think
one just came in then we have one that's
been sitting around which i will get to
um
is it off topic a little bit from alter
here
um is there a way has anyone know how to
connect using r to a olap cube
specifically emma the microsoft analysis
server jd you already have an answer it
sounds like yeah so i tried to do this
what i've run into in our organization
with uh
was it i think they got sql server
analytical services or analysis services
the cube servers colloquially known as
cube servers
the
problem that i ran into was the
kerberos authentication
and i do all of my analytics
on linux based machines
and i think if you're doing if you're on
a windows machine there are libraries
that make this easier
i never got it running because
i was
i was using linux machines and they're
just like i one of our linux gurus spent
some time with it and he's basically
like um
this is awful and hard and not good how
bad do you need this
and
i had the job i was trying to run only
needed to really be run a few times a
quarter so i created a process using the
microsoft tooling
that would export
the uh would run a dax job and export it
as csv into a shared file structure that
i would then pick up with other tooling
uh so my experience is if you run on
linux it's awful if you're running on
windows i think there's a way you can do
it but i wasn't so i don't know
we help customers all the time connect
not to olap but like sql server via
kerberos from linux um for like they're
using rstudio server and we can help
them set up kerberos to connect to
um sql server like all that great
security authentication um i don't do it
myself but the people who work with me
they know how to do it so it is
definitely in they've gotten to the
point where at least for them is no
longer a pain in the butt um because you
know they've been doing it for you know
multiple customers now so um be in touch
and
i clearly need to hire lander analytics
to uh exactly that's the message from
here that's what you need to do
cool
um yes linked server walter mentioned
link server that is a method so you can
link a sql server to your your
analytical services and basically pass
your dax through sql server as a string
and that is absolutely something you
could do that's what my it folks wanted
me to do and i had a great heartburn
with doing that but um
yeah
it's a shame that we jumped all these
hoops we just want to write some
equations down that's
well everybody's mileage may vary with
it with their organization right but uh
i'm really trying to lobby hard for us
to get away from
if we want to use cube servers as an in
reporting for certain things especially
in accounting where they're sort of
addicted to those and used to those
that's okay the problem that i see it is
if you have the business logic between
the database and that reporting engine
if you have business logic in there and
the result of that business logic is
stored only in the cube you've just
painted yourself into a corner and i
think no organization in the year of our
lord 2021 should be doing that if you
put all your business logic in such a
way that you apply that business logic
and it ends up in a table and a database
that's easily accessible from lots of
different tooling and then load from
that table
hashed results into the cube
is in my opinion how it should be uh
being done now i know some of the stuff
in our organization they were trying to
just get it into a cube because that's
what the you know the internal reporting
folks said that they just absolutely
needed it there and they built that for
them and then we quickly discovered
actually we have other solutions that
would benefit from that same data but it
was already painted into that that that
cube corner so
taking a step back and solving it from
the organizational point of view
we're beginning to think about putting
more of that sort of stuff in dremeo
so in our data lake or lake house or
take our pants off and go skinny dip and
whatever i don't know what there's a
swimming analogy in here um
and
the idea is we'll do the business logic
application application of the business
logic before it goes into germio so the
tabular data with all business logic
applied is there in dreamio able to be
used by many different processes some
that are automated like mine but it may
also be populated cube server because
the accounting folks love those and
that's fine i got no like i got no
problem with that it's just that that
getting us with logic trapped logic
in effectively in a reporting solution
is bad him
uh before the last question i do want to
point out you painted yourself in the
corner of a room and a room is just a
giant cube
good point good point well taken
so the last question we're going to do
is we've talked a lot about tooling and
technology here
but remember this meetup is open
statistical programming meetup so we
talk about statistics
what was the purpose of this join of 55
billion rows against 100 thousand rows
and what statistical process for you
so ultimately what we are what we are
heading for is understanding
um
distributions
so ultimately we think a lot about
um
tales of distributions so when things go
bad how do they go bad together so a
whole bunch of what we're ultimately
looking at is
is trying to understand
uh tales of you know lost distributions
within a risk-taking organization
and
that's kind of the the big picture of
what we were doing um
yeah that's a good point and i tried to
make this all very generic because very
few people have the exact problem i had
there but i think more people have
well i've got big chunks of data and i
got big chunky data and i want to do
stuff with it right so we have a bunch
of folks that are going to need to
wrangle some data to do all kinds of
different things uh with it not just the
you know the stuff that i'm doing
we do have more actuaries and insurance
people at these meetups than even you
might realize that's true x-rays have
been doing statistics for hundreds of
years uh so it's very absolutely
so yes
okay folks
so with that we will let our
agricultural economist
uh head off as you don't know jd is
actually by training an actuarial
economist
agricultural agricultural economist so i
work in i work in the reinsurance
industry but my background is i have an
undergrad an undergrad and a master's
degree in agricultural economics we i
like to make the joke about agricultural
economists being the og data scientists
because you know sas came out of nc
state out of the agricultural prop
program at nc state
and of course it's a bit of a joke just
because we have been tracking data and
agriculture for thousands of years
trying to do statistics on it you know
you could also easily argue that
physicists with a bunch of the coding
that they do around uh physics uh
measurements and experimentation they're
the original data scientists right the
actuaries may be the original data
science it's everything's you know we've
been doing the same sort of stuff across
many fields for a while it's just we
didn't have it under one
umbrella now a lot of people don't
realize that minitab came out of penn
state an agricultural program i believe
i did not know that i didn't know that
it came out of an ag program but yeah
penn state's the land grant university
of pennsylvania yep and a lot of these
universities i think that's where doug
bates did a lot of his um you know
multi-level models i think that was
based on he wasn't
agricultural himself but was adjacent to
the agriculture people a lot of these
methods were developed by either
agriculturalists or gamblers
and brewing right so student t-test came
out of out of guinness uh i encourage
anybody everybody who's in this field to
read the book the lady tasting tea which
is the stories
behind where did a bunch of our
statistical tests came from like what
were the people doing when they came up
with these and why did they do them it's
it's a great read it's not a
mathematical read
yeah
it's an energy
with that folks i think we're going to
call it a night it's very late for some
of you all around the world
i would like to thank jd
for uh appearing again in this meetup
where he's been great to be here
great to be here thank you so much for
having me
thank you thank you for being here you
always we always have a fun time with
you here
uh this is going to be online shortly at
nyhackguard.org and on our youtube then
someone's asking for the name of the
book is the ladies tasting the
lady tasting tea so it's the story about
the lady who said she could taste if the
cream was put in and then the tea versus
the tea and then the cream and so it's
basically like how big of a sample size
of that do you have to have to say that
she can actually taste
whether the cream was first or the tea
was first and this is some of the
origins of you know statistical tests
uh going back to the victorian era so
that's what it's named after the classic
book check it out
and if you are in dublin which hopefully
one day we're gonna have our dublin r
conference the guinness tour uh the
warehouse tour has a plaque to the
inventor of the t-test right at the
beginning of the tour and they will let
you take your pint of guinness and go
back to the beginning and take a picture
of it i know from experience
fantastic yeah it is really awesome it's
actually always rated one of the top
attractions in europe better than the
coliseum eiffel tower seriously check
out the ratings
that's awesome
so folks the next few months next month
we have max kuhn we have the rn
government conference december 8th 9th
and 10th we have in january we have
disc.frame in february february we have
a duckdb we'll have other things coming
as we announce them
if you want to speak be in touch we're
planning a few months ahead right now
which is really awesome problem to have
if you have office space let us know we
want to come back in person we need to
get the space
um and everyone has a great rest of your
day
nighttime afternoon wherever you are in
the world enjoy the rest of whatever
time you have left and a big round of
virtual closet jd won't hear for this
great talk thank you very much judy
thank you all for having me it's so
great to see you jared and great to
interact a little bit i i the part i
hate is the lack of being able to see
the faces in the audience and they're
going out for drinks afterwards and
talking about a bunch of stuff but i am
so glad that we could at least do this
week week facsimile of the experience
that we all we all miss so great to see
you
great seeing you too it's always fun
being being around you hopefully i'll
get to see you soon at some point
take care